cela menace d'élections anticipées plane
sur la tunisie le premier ministre
désigné alias farfar a présenté hier
soir la composition de son futur
gouvernement
mais l'un de ses principaux partenaires
le parti islamiste ennahda a annoncé son
retrait il souhaite que cobb tounes
deuxième parti politique au parlement
soit intégré à la formation du
gouvernement
eliès par fars espère trouver un
compromis rapide pour sortir de la crise
malgré nos efforts un des principaux
partenaires je veux parler des narda a
préféré cet après midi une heure avant
l'annoncé se retirer de cette formation
du gouvernement est de ne pas donner sa
confiance lors du vote au parlement
parce que calme tounes s'il n'y est pas
associée
ce choix mais le pays dans une situation
difficile dans ce moment historique
nous avons décidé avec le président de
mettre à profit ce qui reste des délais
constitutionnels
il reste quelques jours un espoir pour
présenter une nouvelle liste devant le
parlement rappelle les céistes hatem
nafti la plus grande surprise c'est que
la liste qu'il a donnée était caduque
dans la mesure où donc il a maintenu la
composition initiale qu'il a présenté au
président de la république qui comprend
des ministres islamistes or le parti
ennahdha officiellement annoncé qu' il
ne participerait pas au gouvernement
avec où il retirait ses ministres donc
après ce discours il a dit qu'il allait
encore se concerter avec le président
pour former un autre gouvernement lui
reste à prier enrayée
quelques jours donc deux à trois jours
pour fixer une liste est passé devant le
parlement parce qu'il est tenu par des
délais qu'on part des délais
constitutionnels et ça doit aller très
vite donc on prévoit sans doute au début
de la semaine prochaine il ya deux
possibilités soit ils diva qui n'y est
pas arrivé il jette l'épongé et il ouvre
la voie à une possibilité de dissolution
de l'assemblée soit il présente une
liste et il va au parlement il vient y
voit s'il arrive à la faire passer